financial help is on the way to assist  the families of officers hurt in the  line of duty  metro's police officers fund was  presented with a check for more than 47  thousand dollars today the money comes  from local taverns that distill at  remedies  if we didn't have the community that we  do the tight-knit community that we do  in las vegas  come together like they do in the time  of need when we have  an injury like shae's or when we lose an  officer like lieutenant eric lloyd  the injured police officer's fund  wouldn't exist the taverns were able to  raise the money with october drink  specials on tito's vodka  and then donating all of the proceeds to  the fund